just as you look for ways to save energy
at your home
well local resorts are doing the same
today mgm resorts is launching a new
effort to try and cut
costs with the help of the sun bianca
holman is live this morning on the strip
to explain bianca good morning
hey good morning sean so you know here
in vegas we do everything big
and so the same would go for saving
energy so properties like
mandalay bay this is a huge announcement
in the hospitality industry it's the
largest renewable electricity project
worldwide so all 13 strip properties
under mgm like mandalay bay and the
mirage will be powered by a 100
megawatt facility and to give you some
context this includes the 36 thousand
rooms and about 90 percent of the mgm's
total power on any given
day so this launch helps the company
reach its goal to reduce the company's
emissions
by 45 percent per square foot mgm
resorts has
other smaller solar projects that
include some panels that line the roof
of the mandalay bay casino and its
convention center
now all 13 strip properties will be
powered by the 100 megawatt facility
and then also just also to kind of give
you where this
is it's located just north of
just in a desert north of las vegas 600
over 600 square feet there and so there
will also be
a ceremony later on this morning and of
course we'll have coverage there will be
the governor there and
other representatives of course mgm
execs
at this major ribbon cutting later on
this morning reporting live from las
vegas strip bianca holman 8 news now